¿Cuáles de los siguientes enunciados son verdaderos,
de las siguientes gráficas? "y" es igual a 3 que multiplica a "x" -5 al cuadrado más 1,
y "y" es igual a 3 que multiplica a "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado más 1? Y antes de ver los enunciados
quiero recordar un poco lo que ya hemos visto en varios vídeos. Lo primero que quiero hacer es un pequeño
análisis de estas 2 gráficas. Fíjate bien si tengo esta de aquí, cualquier valor que tome "x" más 5 elevado al
cuadrado siempre es mayor o igual que 0, por que si te tomas cualquier número y le sumas 5 y lo ellevas al
cuadrado, siempre te va a dar algo mayor o igual a 0 y más aún, de hecho esta expresión se hace mínima,
cuando esto que está dentro del paréntesis se hace 0, es decir cuando esto que está dentro del paréntesis
se hace 0 "y" vale 1 y de igual manera para aquí adentro, a cualquier número, si tú
le restas 5 y lo elevas al cuadrado, te va a dar algo mayor o igual que 0 y por lo tanto si queremos saber
cuál es el valor mínimo que puede tomar esta gráfica,
pues eso se da, cuando esta expresión se hace 0, y entonces "y" va a ser igual a 1.
Todo esto sería 0, simple y sencillamente me quedaría que "y" es igual a 1 y este es el valor más
pequeño que puede tener mi gráfica.
Estos dos conceptos son muy importantes por que en cualquier otro caso,
los valores van a salir más grandes y es más, vamos a intentar hacer la gráfica de estas dos funciones,
en este plano cartesiano que voy a dibujar aquí, y bueno lo primero que quiero que veas es qué pasa con gráficas
como "x" cuadrada más 1. Me voy a tomar primero, no estas gráficas que tengo aquí, sino algo mucho
más sencillo para ir poco a poco,
viendo cómo podemos llegar a estas expresiones que tenemos acá y bueno la primera gráfica que quiero que
analicemos es esta de aquí,
pero esto no parece una parábola, perdón quedó
horrible y ahora si, esta de aquí le voy a llamar
"x" cuadrada más 1, es la gráfica cuyo vértice está en el 1 y además
abre hacia arriba, es decir "x" cuadrada más 1.
Ahora a partir de aquí quiero que sigamos la misma idea, que es lo que va a pasar si primero,
ya se voy a multiplicar a esta gráfica por 3 es decir, quiero ver que me sale de la gráfica
3x cuadrada más 1 ¿Cómo se va a ver eso? Pues sería una gráfica que crece mucho más rápido por que me quedaría
3 por "x" cuadrada más 1 y 3 es un número muy rápido, por lo tanto esto hace que mi gráfica se apriete un poco
más, sigue teniendo el vértice en el 0,1 y la única diferencia de esta gráfica a la inicial, es que ésta crece
mucho más rápido pues, tenemos el coeficiente de 3
multiplicando a la "x" cuadrada. Ahora lo que me voy a preguntar es ¿Qué es lo que pasa con la gráfica
"y" es igual a 3 que
multiplica a "x" - 5 elevado al cuadrado más 1? Y quiero que te des cuenta de algo muy importante.
Cuando esta expresión se hace 0 es cuando "x" vale 5,
cuando "x" vale 5 esto se hace 0 y solamente me queda que "y" vale 1, eso quiere decir que estamos recorriendo
esta misma gráfica,
5 unidades hacia la derecha de hecho va a ser exactamente la misma gráfica que
3x cuadrada más 1 pero, el vértice lo hemos desplazado 5 unidades a la derecha y por lo tanto
esta es la gráfica de la expresión 3
que multiplica a "x" -5 elevado al cuadrado más 1 y date cuenta que se recorrió hacia la derecha 5 unidades
por que cuando "x" vale 5, en la expresión que está dentro del paréntesis se hace 0,
esto es un buen tip para que podamos graficar cualquier
tipo de estas expresiones.
Ahora lo que quiero que veas es que es lo que va a pasar con la otra gráfica, "y" es igual a
3 que multiplica a "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado más 1, pues de manera análoga
esto se hace 0, cuando "x" vale - 5 por lo tanto, va a ser la misma
gráfica que 3x cuadrada más 1, va a tener la misma forma, solamente que el vértice va a estar recorrido o
desplazado 5 unidades hacia la izquierda,
esta es la gráfica de 3 que
multiplica a "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado, y todo esto más 1 y ya con eso tengo las 2
gráficas, y entonces el inciso A, me dice estos vértices que tenemos de tus parábolas son máximos, es
verdadera esta expresión, y bueno un máximo se ve así
entonces, yo veo que éstos no son máximos por que las gráficas
bajan, llegan a un punto y después suben y esto es precisamente la definición de lo contrario,
de un mínimo, por lo tanto esta expresión no es verdadera
y vámonos al siguiente inciso. Dice las gráficas tienen la misma forma pero
diferentes vértices, esto es verdadero las gráficas tienen la forma de 3x
cuadrada, y lo único que pasó es que su vértice se desplazó tanto a la derecha como a la izquierda,
es justo lo que nos dice el inciso B,
y el inciso C por lo tanto es falso,
pues nos está diciendo que las gráficas
tienen formas distintas y eso no tiene sentido, y el inciso D también es falso por que nos habla de puntos
máximos, de vértices máximos y mis 2 parábolas que acabo de encontrar tenían puntos
mínimos, así que vamos a ver otro problema. El problema 37.
Dice ¿En qué puntos? Y es más déjenme mejor
copiar y pegar este problema que tengo aquí, así que ya lo tengo aquí y dice ¿Cuáles son los puntos
en los cuales interceptamos al eje de las "x" de la gráfica "y" es igual a 12x cuadrada -5x -2?
Y bueno no sé cómo se vea la gráfica de esta función pero, se va a ver más o menos así, es una
cuadrática que abre hacia arriba entonces, se va a ver algo así y yo lo que busco son
los puntos de intersección, con el eje de las "x" es decir este y este, y esto ocurre cuando
"y" vale 0. Cuando "y" vale 0
estamos en los puntos de intersección con el eje de las "x", pues cuando "y"  vale 0, no subo ni bajó nada,
es decir estoy enel eje de las "x" por lo tanto me queda que tengo que resolver la siguiente ecuación.
0 es igual a 12x cuadrada -5x - 2
y si te das cuenta esta expresión que tengo aquí no está nada sencilla de factorizar, por que tenemos un 12
a lado de la "x" cuadrada, por lo tanto
factorizar esta expresión no creo que sea la mejor opción, y mejor lo voy a resolver por la fórmula general
que nos dice -"b" pero, en este caso "b" vale -5, entonces me queda 5 positivo
más - la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada -5 al cuadrado es 25
- 4 veces "a" por "c" -4 por 12 por - 2 por que "c" vale -2
por -2 y de una vez menos por menos me dan más entonces estos 2 se hacen más
y a todo esto hay que dividirlo entre 2 veces "a", es decir entre 24 y ¿Qué me queda de esto?
Bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 5 más - la raíz cuadrada
de 25 más 4, por 12 por 2, esto es lo mismo que 4 por 12 es 48, por 2
es 96, 4 por 12 por 12 es 96, 8 por 12 es 96 entonces
25 más 96 entre 24 y esto ¿A cuánto es igual? Bueno me va a quedar
25 más 96 esto es lo mismo que
121 y la raíz de 121 es exacta, esto es lo mismo que 5 más -11 entre
24 y está de lujo por que 121 tiene raíz cuadrada exacto.
Y bueno ya con esto vamos a poder encontrar las 2 raíces que me van a dar las
intersecciones con el eje de las "x", así que vamos a terminar este problema me queda 5 más
11 entre 24, está es mi primer raíz
5 más 11 entre 24 y esto es igual a 16 entre 24, y si saco octava arriba y octava abajo me quedan 2/3,
tercios esto no parece un 3, 2/3 ésta es mi primera raíz.
Así que voy a decir que es esta de aquí y mi segunda raíz es 5 menos, ahora voy a tomar el signo menos
-124, 5 -11 es -6  y esto dividido entre 24,
y si yo saco sexta me queda -1/4, es decir este que tengo aquí, cuando "x" vale -1/4
esta gráfica intersecta al eje de las "x" en el punto -1/4,0
entonces aquí ya tengo mi segunda raíz y ya resolví este problema, perfecto ya tengo el problema 37.
La respuesta es el inciso C así que nos da tiempo de hacer otro más.
Y ¡Oh no! Tenemos un problema por que hay muchos gráficos, así que déjame
achicar un poco estos gráficos, y ya que los tengo un poco pequeños copiarlos y los copian en el
portapapeles que no me sirven de mucho ahí  y pegarlos por acá.
Entonces déjame intentar pegarlos por aquí ya está
perfecto y bueno no cabe justo aquí, déjame bajar la pantalla, jalar esta imagen no cabe.
Pero podemos empezar a mover la
pantalla, esto está más o menos así y me preguntan, y bueno voy a tachar todo esto de aquí para que no nos confundamos,
para que nos quede mucho más claro todo esto y entonces,
esto vamos a eliminarlo, y me preguntan ¿Cuál de estas gráficas
es la verdadera gráfica de la función "y" es igual a -2 que multiplica a "x" -1 elevado al cuadrado más 1?
Y tenemos 4 gráficas y lo que queremos saber es cuál es la correcta.
Así que lo primero que quiero que te fijes es qué es lo que pasaba con la ecuación
"y" es igual a -2x cuadrada más 1.
Antes de pensar para donde se desplaza, lo que quiero ver y analizar es, qué pasa con esta ecuación,
y lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta es que esta expresión "x" -1 se desplaza
1 hacia la derecha por que cuando "x" vale 1
entonces "x" -1 elevado al cuadrado
es 0, que es justo lo que queríamos y además, si esto vale 0 entonces se desplaza 1 hacia arriba,
es decir mi vértice está cuando "y" vale 1, nos desplazamos 1 hacia la derecha, nos desplazamos
1 hacia arriba, y bueno ahora quiero que analicemos la
diferencia entre esta función "y" es igual a "x" cuadrada más 1 y la función "y" es igual a
-2x cuadrada más 1 y lo que cambia es el signo mientras aquí tenemos al 2
positivo al lado de la "x" cuadrada, aquí tenemos al 2
negativo al lado de la "x" cuadrada, lo que quiere decir es que la de arriba
abre hacia arriba, como el 2 es positivo abre hacia arriba, y la de abajo
es una parábola que abre hacia abajo, por que el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x" cuadrada
es negativo. Entonces aquí solamente tenemos 2 posibles resultados.
Estas 2 que abren hacia abajo, ahora bien las 2 tienen el vértice en "y" igual a 1, es decir 1 hacia arriba, por lo
tanto no podemos asegurar nada por ahí.
Pero la gran diferencia es que nosotros habíamos concluido que estaba desplazado a esta gráfica 1 hacia
la derecha, por que cuando "x" vale 1esta expresión se hace 0, es justo lo que vimos en el primer ejemplo,
de este mismo vídeo. Cuando "x" vale 1 entonces esto se hace 0 y la gráfica se desplaza a la derecha,
y por lo tanto aquí tengo que "x" vale 1, se desplazó la gráfica a la derecha y la respuesta correcta
entonces es la C, y bueno yo sé que cuando hablamos de desplazar una gráfica tal vez sea la parte más difícil
de graficar funciones, sin embargo te recomiendo y te encargo que grafíques
funciones, ya sea tomarte la gráfica punto por punto,
o tal vez buscando algún programa que grafíque funciones, para ver cuál es la diferencia entre gráficas,
precisamente cómo está, la cual está desplazada
una unidad hacia la derecha, y la gráfica original, "y" es igual a - 2x cuadrada más 1.
Así que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo.